Pieces of Her stars Toni
Collette and Bella Heathcote
as Laura and Andy Oliver,
whose lives are changed
in the aftermath
of a violent attack.
Get down! Get down!
It features so many twists
and time-jumps
you might need help
untangling them.
I keep waiting
for something real
to come out of your mouth.
With that in mind,
we're going to dig
into Pieces of Her
and explain why
Laura and Andy
have so many people
after them.
Final warning,
we're going to be discussing
spoilers so major,
we might need to go
into hiding ourselves.
Gotta go! You've gotta go.
Before jumping to the end,
it's crucial to know exactly
who Laura Oliver is.
As revealed halfway
through the series,
Laura's real name
is Jane Queller,
the daughter of
obscenely wealthy
pharmaceutical head
Martin Queller,
and sister to Jasper
and Andrew.
Through Andrew,
she meets Nick Harp,
a charming radical
who runs a group
called the Army
of the Changing World.
As the pair's infatuation
grows stronger,
much to her father's
disapproval,
Jane becomes active
in Nick's group,
feeding him information
and helping out with
certain illicit activities.
If you see a car,
flash this three times.
Jane eventually becomes
pregnant with Nick's child,
but decides not to tell him,
a decision with major
consequences for the pair.
And why didn't you tell me?
While keeping
her pregnancy quiet,
they work on a plan
to embarrass her father
at a conference in Oslo.
The scheme backfires
and Martin is shot on stage,
which we'll
come back to later,
and Jane admits
her role in crimes
in exchange
for witness protection.
After serving time in jail,
Jane and her young child,
Andy,
who isn't aware of
her mother's true identity,
go into hiding
in Belle Isle,
-until the diner attack.
-Shoot me!
Jane, now living under
witness protection as Laura,
is concerned for her
and Andy's safety
when the attack goes viral,
and for good reason.
This instant reveals
her whereabouts
to her brother Jasper
and former lover Nick
and forces Andy
to leave Belle Isle,
with her mother giving her
specific instructions
on where to go
and how to get there.
Look, I will call you
as soon as it's safe.
When you hear my voice,
you can come home,
you understand?
Andy's journey takes her
across the country
and the occasional
trampoline park.
As she pieces together
her mother's real identity,
a dramatic twist
late on in the show
sees her kidnapped
by her real father, Nick.
Nick takes Andy to the cabin
where she was raised
while Jane was in prison,
convincing Jane
to head there
to be reunited
with her daughter.
Nick uses this
as an opportunity
to interrogate Jane about
her pregnancy with Andy.
He's also trying
to find a tape
that Jane has been
holding on to.
I will explain the tape
in a moment too.
Where is it?
However, Andy attacks Nick
and sets fire to the cabin.
The tape Nick
was looking for,
as well as the ransom money,
are seemingly destroyed
while Nick tries to escape.
Jane catches up to him,
ready to kill him.
But Andy talks her down
and the FBI arrive
to arrest him.
Of course, to understand
why Nick was on the run,
we need to explain Martin
Queller's murder in Oslo.
Nick's group planned
to have Grace Juno
infiltrate the panel
by posing
as Professor Maplecroft
and then embarrass Martin
by blowing up a dye bag.
Grace was motivated
by losing her family
to one of QuellCorp's drugs.
The plan was simple:
give her handbag
to Martin on stage
where their non-lethal
explosive would go off.
However, Jane spoke to Grace
before she snuck on stage,
telling her that
she was pregnant
and scared of what
her father might do
to her unborn child.
She then convinced Grace
to swap bags with her,
with Jane hiding a gun
in Grace's handbag.
Grace then
fatally shoots Martin
and kills herself.
Back in America,
the group still have
the real Professor
Maplecroft to deal with.
They plan to let her go
after Nick steals
her ransom money.
When the professor tries to
escape from their hideout,
she attacks Nick
and he kills her.
As Nick kills Maplecroft,
the FBI raid their hideout,
forcing the gang to flee
to a remote cabin.
It's here where
tensions boil over
as the group discover Andrew
was shot in their escape
and are divided
on what to do.
What are you doing?
I'm taking Andrew
to the hospital.
Jane, who is in the early
stages of her pregnancy,
begs Nick to take Andrew
to a hospital,
but he violently refuses,
which convinces Jane
to leave him.
She smuggles Andrew
to a hospital,
but it is too late.
While her brother Jasper
joins her
to try and plot a way out
of this situation for Jane,
-she tells him…
-I know all about Oslo.
What?
Don't worry,
we can explain that.
But what about Jasper
Queller's role in all this?
Jane's brother
is an aspiring
vice-presidential candidate.
And when Andy
tracks him down
after discovering
her mum's true identity,
he initially seems
to be willing to help her
out of the kindness
of his heart.
His true motivations
are murkier.
That tape Nick wanted
in the cabin?
Well, it showed
Jasper and Nick
working together
on the Oslo plan,
with Jasper conspiring
to become CEO of QuellCorp.
Jasper gets his wish
of running the company.
But knowing
that Jane has the tape
that could potentially
destroy his reputation,
means he's keen
to ensure her silence.
When they meet
after Nick's arrest,
Jane tries
to convince Jasper
he should find out what
Nick has told investigators,
and he admonishes her
for it.
Jane also reveals to him
that the tape was destroyed
in the cabin fire.
You don't believe me?
However,
when a listening device
planted on Andy's phone
reveals to one
of Jasper's employees
that Jane was the one
who instigated
her father's death,
it gives Jasper the leverage
he craves over his sister,
ringing her
to flaunt his knowledge
and blackmail her.
This call introduces
a major cliff-hanger,
with Jasper now holding
information over Jane
that he'll seemingly
want to cash in.
With Nick's fate
still up in the air,
Jane and Andy
might not yet have escaped
the web of corruption
they're trapped in.
Of course, we want to hear
your theories
on what happened
in Pieces of Her
in the comments.
And if you want
to keep up to date
with the stories behind your
favourite Netflix shows,
be sure to subscribe
to Still Watching Netflix.